for us yeah would you want to come back
to for the quiz
for
eign
yeah
okay and how many are there what why not
uh
give me a second
so we yeah we think
right because if you look at what
happens at n minus one that should be n
minus one
times one and plus one is n inductively
you can prove that the length is n
interesting
with this end it's not a number of
friends it's the length of surpass
essentially
but you're getting here
can you take it for the second
this is Fibonacci very interesting this
gives you uh the Fibonacci sequence
amazing what you can do with data log
and the last one is really hard that's a
these are the Catalan numbers
so data logo person Rings is really
really fun but now I need to switch
slides to talk about termination
okay
let's start with Paris
it's really bizarre because the first
and the second we kind of know for it's
their equivalent right it's the
non-linear and linear transposure but
when you interpret them over the sum
they give you different
yes so the the
um
they are no longer equivalent because we
don't have the identity yeah you're
thinking about the same ring of booleans
yes and the standard data log works over
the same meaning of booleans raised to
the right power to a big Power yes while
here we have as a simmering of natural
numbers
so in that case then linear and
non-linear programs are not the same
they are no longer the thing yes
you'll find the category numbers
even as a Boolean it's not true that
every non-linear program is linearizable
no no but if you take if you take
transit closure you can drive you must
say yeah yeah I'm talking about this
specific example yeah this specific
example I see no but it's at the point
so uh this this uh program uh over the
moon and should be equivalent to this
one this is what uh when Nicole showed
us yesterday when she did uh the
squaring of the Matrix uh uh and you can
do this apparently much faster actually
for data log doing the non-linear
implemented and only a program turns out
to be slower and I think Hank knows they
know much more about this usually the
non-day non-linear one is requires more
work uh but they are equivalent and the
non-linear one takes fewer iterations
yeah discussion but as far as points out
uh over other semi ranks we have to be
careful they are no longer equivalent
yes I'm not sure about the first example
for me the first example computes was a
number of paths yeah if the counting
provenance so it's a black semantics for
uh natural dialogue program that okay so
let's let's see all right so let's say
that uh T of X and if you start with X
from zero so T of X and K is equal to
one yeah so then uh T of zero and N
minus one is one
this is zero
oh there is no Edge you're right
the best way to to make sure your
audience is awake it's five mistakes on
your flight
and this was an honest mistake I really
thought it said
following viruses question do you know
if the last program is equivalent to one
that is
yes
uh but I I really want to focus on
termination because there are so many
interesting things we can discuss here
so this is the purpose of the second the
second lecture to discuss termination of
the naive algorithm when did this happen
um and um just a quick review so we uh
we love data log uh the standard data
log because
um it um it has a well-defined semantics
it's always terminates in polynomial
time but it only works on um on sets
under
um on on such a positive operation not
monotone operations over sets so we
looked at a partially uh ordered
pre-semi ring and we extend the data log
to partially pre-order the same Rings uh
and this is what we call data log with a
ring here as a top data logo
and importantly we actually don't need
to care about pops because convergence
happens in the core semi-ring all the
values over the cycle they are confined
to this course semi-ring which is
naturally ordered so we can restrict the
the entire discussions is this lecture
to naturally order semi-rings as we
analyze convergence
okay so the the right framework to study
convergence of data log is um that of
polynomial equations in smyrink
polynomial equations have been they
occur in many branches of mathematics
and computer science
and as Val mentioned actually back in
the 50s the um the semi-rings were
starting in the context of formal
languages
and informal languages a grammar is
essentially a polynomial equation in a
non-commutative semi ring in the
non-commutative summary of all languages
or the regular languages where the plus
is Union and the multiplication is
concatenation so it's no longer
commutative
we will study we will discuss only
commutative semi-rings
program is equivalent to the um to the
least fixed point of a set of polynomial
equations namely that those obtained by
grounding the data raw program given the
atoms and the input is given the
constant in the input ADB
so this is what I plan to do next to
discuss polynomial equations in a
naturally ordered semi link
okay so we fix a semi-link for now it
doesn't have to be naturally ordered but
we still need it we fix a set of
variables
uh they are blue because they will
correspond to the idbs so this is
something we want to compute they are
not given and um a monomial is what you
expect it's a product of variables two
powers and a polynomial is a sum of
monomials multiplied with coefficients
from our same ring
so here is an example a simple a simple
polynomial and two variables and S of X
this is what file also introduced
yesterday is a set of polynomials with
coefficients in s and with variable X
okay what is a polynomial equation it's
actually a set of polynomial equations
we have n variables and we have equal
and equal number of polynomials F1 to FN
and we are looking for a solution to
um to this system of equations
the determinology I will call it a
polynomial equation uh although it is a
set of polynomial equations
um in short uh X is a couple of
variables f is a couple of polynomials
and we say we are looking for the fixed
point x equals f of x where F now maps
from s to the N to s to the n
of course we can compute the cleaning
sequence uh assuming now that s is
naturally ordered now we need to assume
it's naturally ordered so we start from
zero because in a naturally ordered
simmering zero is the bottom and we
repeatedly apply F because this increase
is in sequence that is our cleaning
sequence and now we know all the theory
if the same ring is Omega continuous
it's least upper bound is at least fixed
Point uh because an Omega
we required the operations plus and
times to be Omega
continuous and therefore every
polynomial is also Omega continuous
okay example oh
um yes but that is a consequence it's
not a definition and any in any um
actually ordered semi-ring the
operations plus and times are monotone
and therefore every polynomial will be
monotone thank you for it's super
important
this is how things fit together
it's fun to look at polynomial equations
and here is a little secret secret the
most important polynomial equation is
this one
it's one plus a x is x equals one plus
ax I wrote it on both whiteboards
because we need it repeatedly
so how do we think about solving this
well we compute the cleaning sequence
and it looks like this we start from
zero we apply a function once the second
time we get this increasing sequence
um and if this converges
um if it's if it's finite then that is a
least fixed point if it's infinite maybe
you have at least upper bound we know
how to think about this but on pen with
using pen and paper
how do we think about the solution of
this equation
well we solve the the equation at the
top as you would do in high school you
just say well X is one by one minus a
and then we expand this as an infinite
series
and that uh formal power series is the
um the solution to our linear equation
in an informal way
okay
this is how we solve a um a polynomial
equation
about a quadratic one
uh what is a cleaning sequence now
well it's more complicated
so we start from zero
we plug in zero now we get B
the second one is BB plugin B here we
get B plus a b squared
and it gets messy pretty quickly
so how can you actually solve this and
we do the same thing like in high school
we solve the the uh the equation we get
a
non-algebraic expression wizard square
root
and now we can expand C the square root
as an infinite series
and uh guess what the Catalan numbers
show up here
very interesting uh so now you you have
the feeling that you can solve any
polynomial equation not so quickly uh
because it's a little trick only works
for degrees up to four Beyond four we
don't have close forms of uh closed form
solutions for polynomials
so in general polynomial equations we
they tend to lead to to power series but
it's not always a case that we can
compute those policies that's what I
mean
where do division and minus come from
and next Gardens
where does a minus uh come from that is
what I'm shifting on under the rug think
of this as a back of the envelope
calculation
um and I don't claim to prove that this
will lead you leave you to
do the correct
um expansion but I believe I'm pretty
sure it's right that this power series
is indeed in a formal sense the um the
least fixed point of this of this
situation
yeah in a way in which I can make formal
in a bit okay
so it takes this as a
method to just do back of the envelope
calculations for polynomial equations
okay good so um a quick discussion in
order to
ensure that the city speaks Point exists
we need to require s to be continuous
um
so uh as some some of you have pointed
out how do we make sure that sscon Omega
continues or how do we extend it to make
it Omega continuous
and there is actually a general way to
do this
for every naturally ordered uh semi-ring
there exists unique up to isomorphism
freely generated Omega continuous
semi-ring which I'm going to denote with
s to the power Omega
I'm pretty sure this is a classic result
but I it's so easy to prove that I just
push it here on the slide so the
algebraic the former property that says
freely generated Omega continuous
sampling satisfies is written here so we
have an uh it comes with an injected
function from s into this extension as
infinity and it has a property
that for any other Omega container
semi-ring if you map uh from s into S
Prime then you can uniquely extend this
function into an Omega continuous
function from s Infinity to S Prime
it's a mouse one uh just forget it let's
let's look at the example this is the
proof how you construct that thing and
I'm not going to read it but I'm going
to ask you if you start with the natural
numbers
and uh you want to compute the 3D
generated
Omega continuous sampling
of the natural numbers what is that said
it's just n using the infinity that's
all you need to add that Infinity it's a
top
what about polynomials
we start with polynomials this is a
naturally ordered semi-ring
but it is not omega continuous you can
construct a bigger and bigger
polynomials by adding more monomials or
increasing your coefficients
and this can grow forever how do we
ensure
that uh how do we compete system to make
it on Omega continuous
Omega Omega concrete
our series but also the coefficients
they uh we need to allow them to also be
Infinity
okay so this has a consequence
if we start with any polynomial equation
in a naturally ordered same ring
then we have uh we are guaranteed to
have at least fixed point that lives in
this um
freely generated Omega continuous memory
it guarantees something exists it
doesn't quite tell you tell us how to
get there and how to represent it but at
least we know that it exists
so I think this is all I wanted to say
about polynomial equations we will see
more about this uh later on as in this
lecture
um
but I want to show you a um
how to how to apply this what is the
connection from between a data logo and
polynomial equations
and this is what we call the grounding
of a data log program
grounding is such a simple concept that
I only have one slide for it
we start from a data log program
we start from an input EDB these are all
the relations that are given to us all
the input relations
and the way we we ground it is that we
construct
we choose n variables and and and
polynomials where n
is a total number of uh idb predicates
that we can construct
using the constants from the input
okay so the input was our database maybe
it consists of the older parts and there
are some parts maybe it consists of the
node in a graph and it has a finite set
of constants
out of those constants construct all the
all the um
um
ground atoms that you can construct
using the the symbols in the idbs the
ones that you want to compute this gives
you an upper bound of what your program
can compute call that thing n
and for each such a potential output
double introduce a fresh variable X
the goal our goal is to compute the
value of that output upper and the value
of that X and that is given by a set of
polynomial equations
a quick example uh together actually the
example comes on the next Slide the
the the
um
kind of the the most natural
let me put it this way uh a special case
of grounding is when we
assume that each input Tuple of the egb
is annotated with a um with an abstract
variable that represents kind of the the
provenance or the the source of that
input upper without permitting to any
particular value in the same ring
and if we do this then we have a second
set of variables this is where it's a
little bit dangerous because it can
become confusing
these variables they represent in an
abstract way
the values that we get from the input
EDB
uh what we want to compute are the blue
ones these are the values of the uh idbs
the ones that we want to compute
and then a program that has a relatively
small set of rules gets grounded into a
possibly much larger set of polynomial
equations where we have one polynomial
equation for each possible
grounding of an idb and the
corresponding f is obtained by grounding
the the rule of the body of that of that
program
yes
yes so actually I don't remember if we
actually stated this in our paper but we
found that if you first solve the data
program in set semantics
then you actually need only those IBB
idb tuples that are in the solutions of
the cell semantics
Club no other idb2 balls in fact occur
in the system of equations
and data you know in practice if you
want to show an example it makes a huge
difference I don't care wasn't aware of
it but it's a very cool observation so
you I I was conservative here and I said
and is all the idbws you can construct
but you can be conservative you just run
the data log program in a traditional
way and that gives you already a more
restricted upper bound of the topic you
care about
very nice
and the the solution to to this um to
these polynomial equations where which
started from this abstract tagging of
the input they were called provenance
power series and the original paper by
um green Cardinal barakis and Val
and I think you can think of them as
generalization of the provenance
polynomials that you get from um for
non-recursive queries for conjunctive
queries and unions of conjunctive
queries
okay I want to show an example because
that's that gives you a lot of intuition
here is our a very abstract data logo
program
so uh
intuitively compute team the single
Source short test pass from from D to
from from a sorry to every node X but it
doesn't have to be single Source short
shortest paths can also be sum of
subparts uh some of the total cost uh
can be anything here because I didn't
commit to a particular smearing the
input relation the input idb is um e is
given by this little graph here so there
are three edges three groundings of the
relation e
and the way we compute the provenance
power series
is by first introducing abstract tagging
the black ones these for every input
atom
these are probably concrete numbers or
maybe they are booleans whatever they
are but we are going to give them an
abstract named z
in addition for every potential output
apple and there can only be two out of A
and R of B for each every potential
output upper we're going to give them
new fresh names X1 and X2
and then we end up with two polynomial
equations one for x one one for X2 which
are obtained by simply grounding this
this program
a solution which now we know how to
compute uh we just eliminate variables
conclude the series and we get this
power series the solutions which are
these to power series are the provenance
uh Power series of uh the output tappers
of this recursive program
it's very cool and kind of gives us an
abstract way to talk about
um the
the
um value of any data log program what
kind you're confused
but you're being quite Cavaliers
and as if they were algebra but in fact
you're using something called packages
in Europe to
justify that if you that you can solve
them with substitution so
right now I'm only sorting them in the
set of power theories so they are
solutions that is power series uh if you
want to solve it in a concrete Omega
continuous memory then you use the fact
that's a set of power series as a free
regenerated
Omega continuous cellular link and
you'll use extent you're just evaluate
that our series
Omega content and then I wasn't planning
to talk about that
foreign
yes
the other one has
very good observation so this is where
you can see the difference
yes it will always have a solution AMD
semi-ring of our cities or formal
policies
this is the power of algebra you you are
guaranteed to have that solution at
least six points that it's at least
fixed point of that set of polynomial
regulations
because we don't know how to find it
that's a big that's a big question yes
ask about the computability of these
things so can we actually have like do
we always have closed from solutions for
that or no the 100 degree exceeds for
then uh it's over I don't know all right
right right however we can always run
the neighborhoods this is where I want
to get yes but actually some some March
you know is I can say so results in our
original paper you can actually for a
fixed monomial given the system of
equations which is
you can actually compute the foreign
okay so um
good so uh uh yeah so we have these
abstract power series
um that you know
so the abstract Solutions of polynomial
equations
but how do we compute them the old data
log systems the way they compute uh the
evaluate data log is using the naive
algorithm is by um Computing the
cleaning sequence and the question is
when does the screen sequence terminate
when does a naive algorithmate that is
the next question to address and this is
where it gets my opinion this is where
it gets really interesting
so um when does it terminate and the the
message will be
that this depends on the algebraic
properties that we have over the same
ring
and I'm planning to discuss four
algebraic properties
and eventually there will be one of them
that is necessary in condition and
insufficient for termination so the four
algebraic properties are a diode
absorptive submitting stable submarines
and non-uniformly stable same rings
uh as as always we are going to denote
with M the number of uh EDB atoms these
are the given values to us and denote
with this blue n the number of idb atoms
these are the unknown variables that we
want to compute
okay the first concept is out of a diode
so a diode is a semi-ring that satisfies
this identity one plus one is equal to
one
uh this is the most boring diode I I
should have replaced it with a more
interesting one this has this property
because or is is um I mean one plus one
or one is one
um some simple properties every uh diode
is either important blood addition is
item potent
because if you multiply this with X then
X plus a 6 equal to X
in a diode a bizarre things happen uh
this tells us that two equals one
if two equals one then you also have
three equals one we have two equals nine
we have uh all sorts of things diode
bizarre
interestingly
three just means one plus one plus one
if you add one three times I abbreviate
that the screen and that means
uh interestingly every diode is
naturally ordered
and the natural order
can be defined as X is less than y if
and only if X Plus Y is y so I'll
mentioned this and um it's equivalent to
saying that plus is at least upper bound
of two elements
okay good so uh what happens if our
semi-ring is allowed
uh does every data logo program
terminate that every particular from on
a diary from you and the answer is no
you can um kind of get this by thinking
about how the freely generated diode
looks like and that is an example for
direct and it's as bad in terms of
termination as any other diet and that
uh if you remember from vals um from
Val's slides that consists of
polynomials over these variables z
um where um all the coefficients are one
we cannot have coefficients too because
2 is equal to 1 and 3 is equal to 1 over
every natural number becomes equal to
equal to one yet we can have an infinite
uh increasing sequence and uh this is
the result of our simplest equation this
one here except that a now is the G over
there
and therefore even the simplest
polynomial equation will diverge in the
freely generated summary which I forgot
how it's called and
the pre-regenerated semiring
a set of polynomials of a b of C oh I
don't think I have a name for it this is
polynomials with booleans as
coefficients but that's just simply
means that it
is
yeah that's exactly
but it is the freely generated item both
and all right where either pixel plus
yeah
the pre-degenerate environment they're
actually also called All That monoids
because you can retain just the times
operation
and then the plus operation is just a
con segment of the order
so there are you can also view them as
as all the Ordnance
good attempt number one didn't help us
too much attempt number two so with the
cleaning sequence may be infinite
doesn't help us attempt number two
absorptive semi rings
smearing is absorptive and if one plus a
equals one this is an identity in the
absorptive simulink and Valor already
mentioned this yesterday
a typical example okay first of all
every absorptive semi ring
is already a diode because you can
simply replace a with one and it's about
it so it is naturally ordered
okay so far so good
um
so um
I think Baldi noted with sorp the the uh
um
but first of all it's a horrible name so
but
you want to put
Square parenthesis is only when it's
actually polynomials with some
coefficients from a specific from
Tanzania
I
when it's otherwise some construction it
just depends on sunset sunset
requirements right so but body is saying
is that this notation should indicate
that this is a set of polynomials well
it's not quite it is a set of
polynomials where we do some
identification and what we need to
identify we need to identify these uh
we need to identify we if if one if one
monomial has tricky as larger degrees
and another monomial then the second
monomial the first Monument is absorbed
you will factor out and it's absorbed so
we only we can only have um
terms that are not not absorptive
anyway this is how I like to Define sort
with or without around parenthesis
interestingly this set satisfies the
ascending chain condition
this is a non-level exercise
okay try to prove that the this up
setups up sort of um
polynomials
A Satisfied the ascending chain
condition
but it does not have a bounded rank
because you can
Z is less than one for the simple reason
because Z plus 1 is equal to one and
therefore V is is less than uh than one
and therefore you can construct these uh
longer and longer chain starting from
week to Decay going all the way up to
one uh and the the this semi ring does
not have a finite element
however it turns out that uh the the
clinic sequence of n polynomial
equations uh has run an n
you apply the naive algorithms and you
can only need to run the score and steps
this might have been known but I don't
think we have found this in the
literature uh this particular this
particular
statement
okay so this is already a success story
if your simulink is absorptive
then the
your data of data or program will
terminate in a number of steps which is
less than or equal to the number of
ground IDP atoms
you you think I'm happy but Happy
I I wanted to make here a comment
uh the the polynomial equations can be
thought of situations in a product of uh
of semi-rings of naturally or the same
rings but the problem is that the
product of absorptive send Rings is not
necessarily absorptive so in order to
prove this this requires incomes sweat
it doesn't follow from simple product
properties yes
offline but I think maybe this is a
consequence of of valves and should
Dippers I study 2014 paper because
they're the construct the circuit
and
the circuit has n steps so I think that
could mean that probably this is this is
like consequence of uh yeah I wouldn't
be surprised yeah but we got it as a
consequence of a more powerful theorem
that I want to show you next
so uh let's talk about stables and rings
and the motivation for this is if you
remember the simple the most important
polynomial regulation which is this one
so as you compute the cleaning sequence
you get these uh these sums of powers of
a
H there is a notation which puts we know
it is from the book by Mondrian and Mino
and
so a to the power parenthesis p p is a
sum of all powers of a up to the power p
uh and uh we we are going to say that
a semi-ring is p stable
if for any a
um a to the sum of the first P Powers is
the same with the sum the sum of the
first P plus one powers
the same is saying that the the cleaning
sequence terminates after P steps
it's just an algebraic an algebraic
condition
are there such stem earrings
and the answer is yes
here is a really cool one
um this same ring
consists of bags of p plus one elements
of
non-negative real numbers
the addition consists of taking two such
bugs
the Excel Union
and to retain just a p plus one smallest
element of the Union
the uh the multiplication
consists of taking two touchbacks
take all pairwise sums
retains a p plus one smallest elements
never exit P plus one
uh why this uh semi ring interesting
when p is zero then
um this this is exactly the tropical
semiring then we only have bags of size
one and the operations are Min and plus
when p is not zero then this limiting
allows you to compute uh like and think
about RPF shortest pass it allows you to
compute the P plus one shortest pass
from a from X to y
so this is the same reading you want to
use when you want to compute the P plus
1 shortest class
okay interestingly and I don't think I
wrote this on the on the slide
um every P stable semi-ring is naturally
ordered
this is surprising just this condition
here for every fix P guarantees that the
semi ring is not already ordered
okay so what do we know about this
notice that it is no longer Omega
continues uh the
hinted there why it's not so what we
proved is that the cleaning sequence of
n polynomial equations also have a has a
finite rank which is a pretty ugly
expression
uh and we couldn't improve it we don't
know if we don't think it's tight we
know that you cannot simply replace here
plus two with p plus one
um but it is at least we have an upper
bound on the number of iterations uh
that the cleaning sequence can take
yeah it's not a convenient this is a
problem so we cannot guarantee that the
data or program definition in polynomial
time because if T is not five then this
gives us an exponential running time for
the data program and that is what I
don't like
okay
yes uh and the the annoying part of our
proof and the theorem is that we had to
deal as a special case for women P0
because when P0 we we get the absorptive
semi rings and we want this to be n but
this formula doesn't give us n which it
had to go through extra effort to
recover that result
when p and when the data log program is
linear
then you can put here P plus one very
strange but again that requires a
specialized treat and the proof to show
that in that case you put can put your P
plus once
okay so is that a necessary condition
for term for uh termination and the
answer is no here is a necessary and
sufficient condition for uh that
guarantees that every data data or
program terminates or uh that every
cleaning sequence of a set of polynomial
equations uh is finite
and the conditions it says
that for every Aid there exists some p
which depends on that a for which
um the the a to the power of the first
term the sum of the first beam powers of
a that's equal to the sum of first P
plus 1 powers of H
just a Brute Force way to saying that
lineage sequence of the simplest
polynomial equation
terminates for or a within a number of
steps that might depend on age
okay
um so um there is a An Elegant semiring
which I actually don't don't have time
to describe
I don't know if there exists a free
degenerated stable semi-ring so I I
don't dare to talk about polynomials
that come from this set because I don't
know how they look like however
we proved that um uh s is non-uniformly
stable if and only if the kidney
sequence of any polynomial on any set of
polynomial equations it's finite
One Direction is Trivial of course uh if
you want all these equations to
terminate then every element needs to be
stable
the other direction is hard proving that
if every element is stable then when you
go to a higher degree polynomial
equation then they are they still
terminate
yes Paris
says that I can find there is some data
log program
four weeks uh it doesn't terminate right
can we say something about a specific
data program so is it possible that you
have a non-stable semitting and a
recursive developed program and use half
termination
it is it is possible so we don't we
don't we did not look at them
okay so uh taking that result and moving
it to data Rock results in a statement
that's actually totally unsurprising it
just repeats what we saw before uh from
polynomial equations to to data log
and I prefer not to talk about this
because I have two more interesting
topics that I would like to cover and I
only have like 16 minutes for two
classical topics
uh the the takeaway so far
uh and this is I think is the most
important takeaway that uh specific
algebraic properties of the semi-ring
they allow us to to reason about the
convergence and the runtime of the naive
algorithm of data log over that
semi-ring
and I think that is nice
um well most of the the runtimes that we
have are probably not not tight uh so
it's an open problem how to
extend to how to improve them I did not
discuss uh the night the seminide
algorithms we have some small progress
in this direction but this is I think
it's still still an open discussion and
I I had to take out the this beautiful
technique that replaces a naive
algorithm with a different method
replaces the cleaning sequence with
something that's called the Newton
sequence that was developed by a Sparta
but as Sparta will be here during the
third workshop and he's going to talk to
hopefully talk about about this topic
what I want to discuss next in only 15
minutes uh is um is the use of a closure
operator
okay so let's talk about the closure
what is a closure operator it is a unary
operator that you add to those two that
you already had in the same ring uh
denoted a star
and the intuitive meaning but it's not a
definition but that would be the
intuitive meaning is that a star is this
uh Power series
remember the most important polynomial
equation
you want you want to have a an explicit
solution for this most important
polynomial equation that is the
intuition behind the power series
so the question is if we have this can
we use the the closure operator to find
explicit Solutions
to every polynomial equation by applying
star
now you already know that the answer is
true for regular Expressions right if
you have a regular Expressions you can
Define them as polynomial equations and
you can always convert them into an
explicit expression that uses star
so uh there are two beautiful classical
results from the literature that that
extend on that observation uh one um one
is on the linear equations in close semi
rings by Lemon it's absolutely beautiful
paper and the second absolutely
beautiful paper on polynomial equations
in green algebra and commutative
clinical Algebra I should say by Hopkins
first one close them rings by uh by
Lemon
his motivation was that he observed back
in the 70s that several algorithms
used similar a similar structure and a
similar correctness proof like War shots
algoris for the transitive closure of a
Boolean Matrix Floyd's algorithms for
the minimal minimum cost pass or even
the Gauss Jordan a message for inverting
a real Matrix
and he introduced a very simple notion
of of a closed semi-ring and he proved
that all these algorithms can be
presented in a unified framework in this
close stami ring
I'm not going to describe the algorithm
but I'm going to describe the close
semi-ring and the key technical
contribution of that paper and that
allowed him to describe this algorithm
so what is a closed same ring according
to Lemon
it is a not necessarily commutative
resemering uh within this additional
unary operator
that satisfies just these two identities
a star is equal to one plus eight times
a star and since it is not necessarily
commutative we also write it as equal to
one plus a star times a
that's it
so uh the most yes
the name is confusing because there is a
concept of closed limiting that means
something completely different and some
of you may recall from reading
actually makes a good point that the
ormond's ormond's book defines this
operator in a complicated way but at the
end you only need this you only need the
star operator with essentially these
accents foreign
okay but let me show you why I find this
super super cool because of everything
that is not required uh so it doesn't
require it is to be a single review it's
a pre-seminine although he doesn't call
it this way he calls it the same urine
but he insists that we do not need his
identity
uh he doesn't require community
uh there are some expected identities
that we expect but he doesn't require
them and they do not follow from the
identities of a gloves what he calls a
close memory
and there is no need to require the same
meaning to be naturally ordered and I
believe that you can find examples which
are not natural
okay so what do we do with the same ring
well he talks about matrices so he's
going to solve linear systems of
equations so matrices are a key the key
technique to a reason about the
existence of equations
and we have to be careful because the
Matrix is say Do not immediately form a
uh pre-semuring the problem is that
multiplication with the identity is not
equal to a is it something that lemon
points out
why is it not equal to a well because we
are missing uh the absorption rule so
when you multiply the uh the terms you
don't need with multiplying with them
with zero they don't disappear
that is the main result
so we we uh we I do not claim that they
form a closed same ring
whatever we claim it right now okay uh
so uh the um what what Layman proven
this is a beautiful result is that there
exists a construction which gives us a
closure of a matrix which satisfies
exactly the identities of a closed
emiring and the way he proves this by
explicitly describing the closure of a
matrix
he says take your Matrix divide it any
way you want such that the diagonal
block matrices r squared
and he simply defines it
um Boom the a star is equal to this
definition here and you can use the
closure of the smaller Matrix is because
it defines them you you construct them
inductively
so Grace you don't need to write them
it's way way too long I can send you I
can sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
that um
for me it's a pain to write that formula
so I don't want others to suffers with
the same thing so what does
so what's the closure of a single value
we have the the basic closure operator
and this is what we use for the base
case
that is a star you are because you live
in a closed simmering
yeah and the beauty of lemon theorem is
that he extends this from a simple
single elements to matrices
so he he proves to main results a star
is well defined we don't care about how
we split it we get always the same
result
and moreover a the closure of a matrix
satisfies the same identities uh of um
of a closed same ring
in particular if you're looking for a
set of polynomial equations that are
linear that can be written like this
then its solution is described by by a
star times p
this requires a verification you need to
take this expression plug it in here and
then use this identity to prove that it
is a fixed point
this is really a beautiful result so I'm
going to wait a few seconds for people
to
um internalize it
yes you're unhappy you're happy
so is this the simplest definition
because this this is related to Auto
suspensions yesterday so there is a
reduction from
it's exactly this formula
because if you want to compute the
the closure of an N by n Matrix
we only need two closures of M of the
two by one of the two matrices
so it
you won't lose anything
so I wonder whether there is a simpler
definition which is not as efficient but
might look simpler
uh so I don't know the answer
but I know that lemon makes a point of
saying that if you if you add these
identities and I think uh yeah there is
a second one which I did which I
recommended if you are this identity
plus a second one then you can simplify
this definition and you recover it
simplify the definition that has existed
before in the literature but as far as I
remember his algorithms are are cubic
Les
so I I don't know
other questions yes a linear system I
would have thought of it as ax equals B
and this is special okay
yes uh so I should have mentioned this
whenever we talk about polynomial
equations whenever I talk about linear
locations you always think about six
point equations
ax plus b equals X
interestingly if you look at um that
polynomial equations which are not fixed
point
they have been studied uh it's a very
deep Topic in algebra they are
beautifully described in Stanley's
combinatorics volume 2.
and I I really don't know that area but
there is one fascinating observation
there you need to to drive solutions you
don't need your power savings we also
need fractional powers
the powers of the form x to the power 1
by n
for the simple reason because you can uh
you can say well uh D to the power n is
X so what is D is X to the power 1 by n
beautiful Theory I'm not not qualified
to talk about that uh we own it of about
six point equations they seem to be
syndrived then yes help me understand
something we went from the data log
where we wanted a list fixed point
equations now this gives us a solution
but how do you go to the resolution yeah
so that is my question so uh can we use
this to evaluate data because exactly as
you pointed out um
uh I didn't write it here but this this
is my question so maybe it comes on the
latest line uh can we use uh disclosure
operator
to artillery maybe the naive evaluation
algorithm
uh to compute the answer of data of the
natural score and I don't know
I did I still need five minutes to talk
about the second fascinating extension
which is causing
um
I'm confused 1977
1977 yes
yes
what's the implication for
there's a lot of termination on clothes
um
[Applause]
I I think you can have a close centering
where you if you run if you run like the
neighborhood with no terminate
the fact that you have a name all these
things you have you have a you have an
expression you define fixed Point yep
but that's not the semantics necessarily
of the program right uh maybe this is a
semantics but if you start if you're if
your data interpreter is given this
program
uh and it has a fixed Point um it has an
explicit solution but if you start
evaluating the naive algorithm if the
algorithm doesn't know that there is a
an explicit solution which simply
evaluates this this sequence which might
be
but that is exactly my question how can
we exploit the fact that we have an
explicit Construction
let me show you the second one because
it really I hope you will be with me
another five six minutes
um so the uh the second result that I
want to show you is about commutative
clean algebras this is actually two
motivations the original motivation for
codes and uh when he introduced a
cleaning algebraz was to find a complete
axiomatization of regular expressions
I don't know if you remember playing
with regular expressions and you get
these bizarre identities and you start
wondering what about what are all of
them how can I compute all of them well
it turns out and I know this from from
cousins paper that red core uh proves
that not finite no finite axiomatization
of all the identities of a regular
Expressions exist and causes credits
this to a a paper in Ukrainian
um yeah so I did not read that paper let
me put it this way uh so um
uh so there is no finite activation
however kozen defined uh clean algebra
which are semi Rings pluses uh um closer
operator and he showed that um
if you allow conditional axioms this was
actually known before but his actions
are very elegant if you allow
conditional accents like uh horn Clauses
then they form a complete axiomatization
of uh the identities of regular
expressions
okay but we are not interested in in in
non-commutative cleaning algebras which
are necessary for regular Expressions we
are interested in commutative cleaning
algebras
and here kozan had a second result which
has another beautiful motivation
motivation number two
and this comes from Paris theorem
so Paris in 1966
he proved the following that if you
think about
languages but commutativity you make it
sorry you make concatenation commutative
to say that concatenating towards you
can you can apply commutativity
then every context-free language
becomes equivalent to a regular language
so for example here is a context-free
language a to the n b to the end or
undergrades this is not a regular
language
but if you allow commit activity this is
the same as a b star
this is a beautiful CRM of uh Parikh
theorem it works for Strings
what Hopkins and cousin did they showed
that this CRM also extends to any
commutative clean algebra
and I hope you have your attention I
need one or two more minutes to show you
the result so what are these opinion
algebras again I'm fascinated by the
Simplicity of of an algebraic structure
so a clean algebra is a diode
it needs it needs to be either important
and um the the um the multiplication is
commutative so we need them
and it it's a diode it is naturally
ordered and the the closure operates the
star operator must satisfy these two to
identities their inequalities pretty
comparisonment to identities and these
conditional identities the conditional
is critical because they remember Red
Cross CRM otherwise we can't get a
complete multiplication of regular
expressions
um
so this is a um a clean algebra
so now the resulting that I want to
mention is
um what Hopkins and cause improved in 99
that if s is a commutative clean algebra
then every polynomial equation has a
unique solution
no need to worry about at least a fixed
point at least prefix point that is a
unique solution which of course is also
the least uh fixed point that is
anything you want because it's Unique
and the example that they give in this
paper is another Twist on um essentially
CRM you take a grammar this gives you a
non-linear set of equations but under
commutativity axb is the same as ABX and
it's a unique solution is again A B ABC
so we have seen two extensions of same
urines to uh to to with a closure
operator
um
and they are sufficient to talk about
Solutions of linear regulations and um
Hopkins and causing cause and
commutative cleaning algebras they can
solve arbitrary polynomial equations
the question on my mind is
um can we use any of this for data load
and I don't have I don't have an answer
okay and that is that is it so let me
skip the conclusion because I know we
are running late but I want to leave you
with uh some open open problems on
in the screen and I will stop right here
[Applause]
sorry I was confused by the example
about parentheses you said the solution
is 80 star
I need to go back
to say this is the language
and the solution so it's it's not the
language of well-parently say it's word
suggestion is that it's it has the
synthetic image exactly because this
language has the same body image as this
language the Public Image just keeps
track of the number of occurrences of a
symbol
okay so I didn't check this carefully
but it's in their paper okay I saw it a
little bit that seems very great
yes so which all the things can you say
about the new systems
we can apply lemons lemons so there is
an eight weeks we can complete the
closure of the Matrix using the star
operator and that is the explicit form
of a solution
in the social order
linear programming
I don't know I should mention that lemon
in his paper also showed that with the
same framework he can capture the
inverts of a matrix
for the inwards I don't remember how you
missed before I did pay too much
attention to that detail but it's really
beautiful paper so you can express the
inverse of amazing since the same format
foreign
effective
as it is exactly this is
right thank you
[Applause]
thank you